on new trends and scholarly
communications the series as a whole is
called research without borders the
changing world of scholarly
communications and today's discussion is
on the future of learned societies it's
being co-sponsored by the office of the
provost as well as the center our
Provost Claude Steele is oft on a
Provost 'i'll trip as I'm sure Jim will
will know from his own experience and
unfortunately couldn't come I'm Steven
rittenberg I'm the senior vice provost
the the center for digital research and
scholarship is dedicated to serving the
Columbia community in several different
ways it develops new ways of
communication using the new information
technologies it works with individual
faculty in using those technologies and
it sponsors events like this to educate
the community about important new
developments in scholarly communication
the series has six part Tillett the
first one had to do with blogging which
I'm still not quite certain exactly what
it is but it's blogging with particular
emphasis upon blogging by feminists
future sessions will deal with open
access journals with PubMed that which
is the V online database for scientists
in the life sciences and the
implications of of open data initiatives
for funded scientific and scholarly
research so our featured speaker today
is james o'donnell the provost at
georgetown
you'll also be hearing from Eric
Weinberg from our department of physics
Provost O'Donnell has a long and varied
career as a scholar as an innovative
leader in the use of information
technologies a scholar of ancient
Mediterranean history and culture he
received his PhD from Yale and before
moving to Georgetown taught at Bryn Mawr
Catholic University Cornell and pen
somewhere along the way he acquired a
considerable interest in how information
technologies can be used to promote
higher education and scholarly research
he helped to found one of the earliest
online journals and the humanities he
began to use the internet as an
educational tool when it was neither
common or or easy to do and for several
years he served as the information the
vice provost for information systems and
computing at the University of
Pennsylvania on a more personal note I
discovered by looking on the web that he
grew up watching rockets launched from
the White Sands Missile Range in New
Mexico and has a town in Texas that has
been allegedly named after his family so
professor Weinberg who will be
commenting on his talk is a full
professor on our Department of Physics a
product of the ph.d program it hard he
joined Columbia shortly after getting
his degree and has served here in a
variety of capacities including as chair
of his department he works he's a
elemental elementary particle theorists
who has worked in the areas of quantum
field theory and cosmology and more
recently has been interested in
properties of black holes I'm a
historian by background then I can't
resist the temptation to say that some
of the sounds like Greek to me so in
addition he has been very active in the
american physical society where he has
been a fellow for many many years and
has also been very involved with its
scholarly journal scientific journals
and actually is serving and has been
serving for i guess over a decade now as
editor of the Physical Review d which is
a leading journal in elementary particle
physics field theory gravitation and
cosmology so I would ask you all to join
me in welcoming Provos james o'donnell
and a professor eric lender
thank you Steve good afternoon everyone
thank you for coming out this talk has a
history it began with as talks often do
a title and a good intention it's now
having a history because I find myself
on the road this fall in a variety of
settings in which I thought it would be
useful for me to try in different
settings with different perspectives for
different audiences to talk about some
things that I'm finding important in my
own work and that I think have a broader
importance in the profession at large I
say that by way of explaining that there
may come a point in this talk when you
think I have wandered off down a garden
path that is the logical result of
having written the talk given it once
before and thought about what I learned
from that I gave it two weeks ago at the
university of delhi in in india at
something called the International
Conference of academic librarians which
was the first such held on the Indian
subcontinent hundreds of librarians not
only from India but from surrounding
countries i met nepali iranian and iraqi
scholars in the course of that and found
it as i always do in such settings
valuable to think about my concerns in a
setting in which there are very many
other concerns concerns that are not
mine and to think about how we arbitrage
and connect ourselves across this global
community that emerges my theme is the
future of learned societies the learned
in society goes back several hundred
years we believe we know that the Royal
Society in London published the first
thing we call a scholarly journal in
1665 and one of the things learned in
societies do is publish journals indeed
the reason I could be sure I would be
able to meet this obligation in New York
and not be sucked off on some other
provo steel trip is that I'm here for
the board meeting of the American
Council of learned societies and one of
the criteria that we have for membership
in the ACLS to determine whether
something is a learned society is indeed
whether it publishes a journal and how
you administer that
technical requirement is an interesting
one in these in these days but indeed
learning societies are often defined by
the way they support publication my
particular and yet more personal reason
for this set of concerns is that for my
sins I am serving the four-year term now
is vice president of the American trilla
logical Association for publications and
I inherit a journal a monograph series a
text book series and the obligation in
that for years to appoint new editors
for each of those three and to think
about what the directions of the society
in the directions of its publications
might be so I'm going to begin a bit by
talking about that association and what
the presenting symptoms as it were in my
life happened to be and then go on a bit
of a journey of meditative exploration
about what might be real issues that
stand behind some of the apparent issues
facing an organization like this the
American fill illogical association was
founded in eighteen sixty nine it is one
of the oldest learned societies in the
United States when it began we had
responsibility for the phila logical
examination of languages whatever they
might be at various points other
languages another profession spun
themselves off from us so we don't see
as many articles on Sanskrit in our
journals and publications as we used to
and the foundation of the linguistic
society of america in about nineteen
twenty created a different in fact
embodied the creation of a different
discipline and much of what we had felt
responsible for before them went away of
the APA at this point is essentially the
professional home for classicists for
people who worry about the Greek and
Latin world's not including
archaeologists the archaeological
Institute of America is the home for
them but the APA and the AIA come
together for three days every year meet
two for joint meetings periodically
discuss getting divorces because some of
us develop they believe in meeting
between Christmas and New Year's and
some of us devoutly believe in meeting
the week after and we've had that war
going on for
20 years at the moment there's no talk
of divorce and we're all perfectly happy
and friendly together embodying for
those few days each year this year it
will be just outside the gates of
Disneyland no comment what it means to
study the Greek and Latin tradition and
the worlds in which those languages were
spoken the journal is the point of my
particular interest in concern at this
moment and I'll say a word or two about
it it was founded as the transactions of
the American Phil illogical association
in 1869 in 1897 the title was changed to
transactions and proceedings of the
American Phil illogical Association and
for over 70 years the volumes were
published incorporating the papers
delivered at the annual meetings and
such other reports of committee reports
accounts of business accounts of
treasurer's report and that sort of
thing embodying the business of the
association in a single volume in those
days already we saw that the journal was
published annually in a kind of maroon
buck room and I well remember that when
I was an undergraduate I judged the
wisdom and maturity of my faculty guides
and mentors by the long row of maroon
buck room volumes growing on the shelf
behind their desk I remember the pride
and pleasure with which in 1976 I got my
first one and imagined that this row
would grow now extending all the way to
infinity because I am going to live
forever one or two things have happened
along the way in the year nineteen
seventy three disappeared mysteriously I
just checking these numbers last night I
said I realized I can't remember what
exactly happened in 1973 I was almost in
the profession them but the proceedings
part went away and we went back to being
the transactions of the American for the
logical Association for a couple of
years small pamphlets were published
called the Proceedings of the APA that
then morphed into a newsletter and I
leave to one side the archival and
library concern about what happens to
recording the business of our
association when it's no longer
incorporated in the back pages of our
journal but instead is in a newsletter
that I am pretty sure is not being
collected with the assiduous pneus
which our journal is being collected
anywhere another thing that happened in
that time is that our annual meetings
grew when I was young there were a total
of thirty or forty papers being given at
one of these three day meetings at the
end of the year the last summary number
i saw suggested we now do about 400
talks at the meetings in to publish all
four hundred and the course of the next
year would require several volumes we
don't do that so in fact the gap between
what is the transactions and proceedings
of the association in congress assembled
and what shows up in the journal has
widened considerably the one thing you
can say with reasonable probability is
that the presidential address would
appear in the journal after that
articles may or may not have had a
former life as talks at the at the
annual meetings the row of maroon
volumes did indeed extend across the
shelf behind my desk in my office at the
University of Pennsylvania for many
years until about ten years ago then
reality intruded and we discovered two
different things one was a new
publishing partner the johns hopkins
university press didn't much like the
idea of doing annuals and we discovered
that doing annuals in modern American
research libraries meant nobody would
see you because the annual volume shows
up in the library and is immediately
stickered and moved to the shelf the
soft covered journal fascicle on the
other hand moves to the journal
periodical reading room the departmental
seminar room something like that and we
discovered that by moving from hardcover
to softcover we could save money and
develop a larger audience improving as
well our production stream because we
now due to issues a year instead of one
I'm still in denial about this so my
long row of buckram volumes are actually
shelved behind a row of other volumes in
my kitchen at this particular moment and
the new softcover fascicles which really
quite handsome and have the same maroon
coloring about them are now leaking
around there we've gone through about 10
years of though of those this is a
journal of distinction and importance
one measure of that is I can tell you
that the Columbia University Department
of classics none
both a past and a future editor of the
tap in its on its faculty gyms eps
elizacass to editor katrina foulke is
coming in next january i will give you a
sense of the urgency of concerns with
which editors deal nowadays to tell you
yesterday's email firestorm which arose
when we discovered that because we
accepted an article for next the next
issue which contains a significant
gallery of gas what a thought
illustrations images pictures we were
just on the point of producing an issue
which together with the plastic bag in
which we mail it would go just a Titch
over or might go just a Titch over
sixteen ounces in weight i should tell
you the united states post office is not
thrilled by this prospect and proposes
to establish a substantial surcharge in
its on us in the order of several
thousand dollars of mailing if we allow
ourselves to go over so the critical
editorial task for yesterday was to
figure out if the pages can be
rearranged and the illustrations done a
couple of pages left out to keep it down
to the point where you're really sure
that it won't weigh 16 ounces but one
problem in this is you don't know
whether it beats the post office wait
until you have the thing itself the
plastic bag and the person in a blue
uniform all in the same place together
and if the person the blue uniform
thinks it tips over 16 ounces you're in
trouble so you wind up aiming to come in
a little low you know this is one of
those business moments where everything
that I've just described to you makes
perfect sense but if you kind of pull
back the camera and say what are these
grown-ups doing you have to say this is
nuts this is not exactly work for
serious responsible scholars this is not
what we went to graduate school for but
it's the kind of bind we find ourselves
we find ourselves in we're going to have
a retreat this winter Adam Ant O'Hare
Airport Hotel in which we bring together
members of the associations publications
committee and a few other officers and
former officers of the organization to
talk about what it is we should be doing
and I suppose the way I can describe and
defend this talk I'm giving say it's
evolved from the point at which we would
spend most of our time talking about the
16-ounce prob
and be able to talk about issues that
really do affect what it is we imagine
we're doing when we publish serious
scholarship in the early years of the
21st century so here's a point at which
I need to turn a bit of a corner here's
a piece of text that I would like to
read to you I'll tell you once it comes
recently but I found it because of my
continuing interest in my dissertation
topic and my pursuit of new material and
new evidence on that topic now lo these
30 years later and i quote got and
compelling query a while to she that
took a lot of inspect but which was also
sheerest educational the questioner
wrote interesting call for i was
recently researching josh McDowell's
evidence that demands a verdict and in
chapter 5 he on the mostly provides
basis of the Bible's survivability all
the technique through meanwhile he
points dated that the Bible has survived
longer and on the mostly has been copied
so distinct more times than other works
isn't that a tuma faction of a
half-truth I hear tell with the case
church hardened to fling away
non-christian creative writings or
abolish it as in the Josephus
authentication where a Christian grave
added in the subdivision and net Jesus
if you were like me there are whole
moments in what I've just read that
almost seemed to make sense one person I
showed it to the tomb a faction of a
half-truth now isn't that a phrase isn't
that language being used just at the
margin in a perfectly transparent kind
of way it goes on I'm not going to read
you the rest of this but the Islamic in
every respect on the other meter did not
suffer the accommodating of
disheartening ages that the Christian in
every respect did you know that's
getting that's almost English in several
respects how did I find this well I
found this because i have a google alert
set on the name of cassiodorus my
dissertation topic of 6th century
scholar and monk who lived in italy
worked in government worked in how to
add a monastery copied manuscripts wrote
a great many books so i set my google
alert and i have one
Google Alert to track him down I get
fewer hits on that than I get on james
o'donnell because it turns out that
james o'donnell is also the CEO of BMW
North America the CEO of american eagle
outfitters and the organist at
westminster cathedral so i have to do a
certain filtering on the information
that i get through that one but i don't
hear about cassiodorus unless we're
talking about cassiodorus and that's the
good news so this one comes from a
perfectly respectable sounding address
paganism edublogs.org if any of you are
particularly fond of james joyce's later
writing i recommend it the it's a
puzzling web page and i have not made up
my mind what to make about it there is a
seriousness about it the listing of
months of prior pages of this blog
running down it's one of these standard
blogging softwares the listing of the
months gives the names of the months in
finish which is interesting and some
part of me wonders whether this stuff
has been machine-translated feed the
finish into a computer translator and
get this english coming out the other
side perhaps perhaps not i'd like to
know what the finish for to my faction
of a half truth is because it is indeed
a beautiful kind of phrase if you are
interested this stuff goes on and on and
on and i've been checking i found this
about a month ago i've been checking
back there's more of it every day and
it's all like this and it is always it
betrays a kind of serious intellectual
interest glimmers of seriousness of
intellectual performance though i give
you a sample here which suggests that
the underlying interest is an amateur
scholars obsession with bible study
authentication of the Bible Bible texts
and so forth there are lots of those out
there there are none that are anything
quite like this my reason for lingering
over this is that I well remember
vividly remember that when I was a
graduate student prowling in those days
every single level of the 15 layers of
the stacks of the sterling Memorial
Library in New Haven finding material
for my dissertation indeed on
every single one of those stack floors
there wasn't anything like this for me
to deal with this was not part of the
scholarly discourse on my dissertation
topic I didn't have to worry about this
kind of thing now one respectable move
of the last decade or so has been to
dismiss the internet generically dismiss
the kind of stuff you find on the
internet and for want of a better word
bury your head in the sand comfortable
and confident that the transactions of
the American fill illogical Association
for example will be able to save you
from having to take any such thing
seriously here's where my trip to India
and some other contacts in the last year
give me pause the liveliest moment of
the International Conference on academic
libraries in India was on the argument
broke out among the participants on the
question whether the Internet is a
library or not I think I am happy to say
that the majority prevailed and arguing
that the internet is not a library and
most of you could reproduce the argument
that would be made to demonstrate that
but there was a strong presence in the
room of people who live on a
subcontinent in which educational and
cultural institutions are mostly
underfunded difficult of access
University of Delhi has 150,000 students
if students are separated among 68
different colleges in the delhi area the
limited library facilities on the campus
in north delhi are on a good day and
hours drive away on a bad day they're a
lot further away from that they are
small they are cramped they are crowded
the vice-chancellor whom I met is not
sure where they're going to put things
and is puzzled by the fact that people
seem to need air conditioning when they
show up to come and sit in in libraries
as well and he understands that we
believe that the materials also need air
conditioning he doesn't know how he can
provide any better facilities than he
now provides for that kind of audience I
can well imagine that there are many
very serious people pursuing academic
scholarly and research topics of
considerable importance with the
greatest seriousness for whom the
Internet is as good as or better than
an any library to which they do
themselves genuinely and personally have
access and no amount of pious protesting
on my part no amount of sententious an
authoritative statement on the part of
those in the room who are holding out
for the internet not being a library
will persuade people otherwise my other
point of contact from this and I
recognize that the plural of anecdote is
not data is a young scholar whom I met
when he stood up in a room like this and
asked me a question when I had given a
lecture at Fudan University in Shanghai
it was perhaps the best question I've
ever been asked after a lecture in my
life and it involves comparative
analysis of my own scholarly work
without a two of two or three other
distinguished Anglophone scholars
working in the same period so after I
standard my way through the answer and
answered some other questions I made
sure to pull this fellow aside ha dong
chi is associate professor of history at
fudan university with a PhD from renmin
university in shanghai and sorry in
beijing other than otherwise known as
people's university the one that now has
a statue of Confucius on the camera on
the campus where you would not have
expected to find a statue of Confucius
30 years ago his dissertation advisor at
Renmin was a Chinese scholar who had
taken a doctorate in canon law at the
Catholic University of America and
professor Shaw had done his own
dissertation which he was pleased to
give me a copy of later in two very
substantial volumes on agustin city of
god the volumes are in Chinese I've had
someone look at them enough to tell me
that they are what they say they are the
one scholarly judgment I can make is
that the bibliography is much of it in
Roman characters and by golly he's done
a very good job he's been reading the
right things um he has a substantial
bibliography of material that should be
in a contemporary study about a custom
city of god so I've been in touch back
and forth by email and once indeed got
to see him in the United States when he
came to the States as a chaperone of
sorts for Chinese students and I will
just say it's interesting to talk to
someone who's working on Agustin in
China there are aspects of Augustine's
attitude
towards human sexuality that challenging
as they might be for an Anglophone
European society are completely
impenetrable to a society of young
people who have grown up under Mao ism
in China I'm learning a lot from this
conversation the disconcerning moment
came when I published another book and
about and I sent dr. Shaw a copy and he
thanked me very warmly for it by email
but it took a while for it to get out
there and he said he'd already gotten
the electronic version the electronic
version I said yes and he gave me a URL
and I went to the URL and found that
indeed harpercollins had published an
ebook version of my book and about 20
minutes after it was published it was
bootlegged onto this site which is a
download site for distributing
electronic books around the world and my
friend dr. Shaw was delighted that he
would be able to share my book with his
with his students I expressed my sharing
of his delight in measured and
restrained tones sent an email message
to my publisher and what away scratching
my head some more over just what to make
of this but indeed he tells me in cold
prose that access to library research
materials for the kind of field he works
in is a significant challenge for him it
generally involves travel and it
generally means that there will not be
in China the kind of adequate materials
that he would need to be a recognized
scholar of standing competitive with my
other students who were working at
american and european universities I on
some several parts of my brain
disapprove of that site and several
other parts of my brain fully understand
how that site comes about and recognize
the rationality and even the
responsibility of the individuals who
are trying to get the best information
they can use the best information they
can by whatever means might be possible
that's the world we live in so let me
linger for a moment on the world we have
left behind by point of comparison and
then try to draw a lesson from that this
is the marquee should be all named muffy
a gentleman of Verona in the early 18th
century a polymath of various kinds a
troublemaker of Barry
kinds but a scholar of no mean
accomplishments I've known and told this
story for years but it's a great story
about information technology whatever
else it is in the Year 1713 in
conversation with the chapter librarian
at the Cathedral of Verona Maffei II was
encouraged to believe that there were
more manuscripts in the library than
they had yet found and so one day he and
the chapter librarian go ruling about
and they go into a darkened back room or
a very large armario that's Latin for
armoire and that's what books used to be
kept in was standing up against the wall
and they looked at it and they opened it
and it had interesting old books in it
but they got interested in the top of it
and thought there was something funny
about where the top of the case was and
where this inside ceiling of the case
was so they went to fetch a ladder and
they climbed up and they found that on
top of the armoire there were loosely
attached wooden slats and under those
slats manuscripts at that point Maffei
did not have a good estimate of how old
those manuscripts were or how long they
had been their best modern scholarship
suggests they had been on top of that
armoire under those wooden slats for
about a hundred and fifty years the
manuscript that I know about this from
that brought this to my attention was a
manuscript of the work of my friend
cassiodorus it is a manuscript dating
from the 6th century it is probably not
by cassiodorus own hand or his
scriptorium but probably a first first
generation copy of that there aren't a
lot of manuscripts of that vintage
surviving in that condition but indeed
it came down from off off top of the
armoire and was in perfectly good
suitable usable condition a parchment
manuscript and contained a work of
cassiodorus of which we knew from his
other writings but which we had never
had a copy of before and so in 1721
Maffei publishes this with great pride
it has the distinction of being the
dullest and least important work that
cassiodorus ever
but never mind now I used to want to
believe and I think I may have said in
my dissertation that the manuscript had
been there on top of that cabinet for
over a thousand years and I was
disappointed when I reviewed it recently
and found that it was only 150 years but
speaking as one who has not yet lived
150 years 150 years is in fact a very
long time and it's a very long time in a
society in which people don't live to 80
and 90 and a hundred years old those
books had been out of human care and
attention unbeknownst to anyone in that
chapter library for several generations
of care and keeping and yet when they
came out they were in fine condition
they still contained all the information
that they had originally contained and
all of the software and hardware you
needed to process them was readily
available to you now I told this story
for 15 years in some form or another by
way of compare and contrast to the
technology of digital information which
by and large does not rest on top of
bookcases and armoires for 15 years much
less 150 years much less a thousand
years and turn out then to be turn out
then to be readable in any meaningful
form if you are like me and you have
some boxes of floppy disks that you
never converted over to hard disks I
think I have some bad news for you you
might want to talk to me about it
afterwards but they may not actually be
floppy disks anymore in fact it's
probable that they are that they are not
but what strikes me as we continue to
live through the age of digital
information is not the mere fact of
preservation but something else about
the fact of quantity so I made a
nuisance of myself and I asked my
gracious hosts to fetch these volumes
out of is it the ancient and medieval
Medieval and Renaissance and HankMed
ancient and medieval seminar room these
two volumes were published in the 1860s
in Paris by the Albania they are volume
69 and 70 of something we can look
really call the petrol ogia latina
the real title when extracted by
bibliographies runs for several lines
the definitive book to date on the
editor of these was written by a then
member of the Columbia faculty Howard
block it was called God's plagiarist
about the abidjan pole mania who spent
the middle years of the 19th century
publishing the church fathers and other
works of useful theology in Latin and
Greek in cheap editions for the use of
the parish clergy of the French Catholic
Church so these two volumes are two of
225 which embody the work of the Latin
Church from the earliest writings in the
2nd century down to the 13th century
when he finished this series the of
Amina turned around at another hundred
and seventy some volumes of the Greek
fathers and there are whole raft of
encyclopedias and collections of
scholastic theologians and whatnot he
was a one-man publishing industry the
particular piece of evidence on which
Howard relied for his monograph was in
fact a dossier that was found on the
abidjan pool mania in the archives of
the Paris police who had had more than
one occasion to inspect his business
dealings over time this is cassiodorus
my man cassiodorus fills about half of
this volume and all of this volume about
1,200 columns all but 80 columns of that
had been printed in addition by the
French Benedictine John Garre in 1679 in
Paris I was lucky enough to find a copy
of that a few years ago at a price that
I could just about afford but I didn't
think it would get through it would get
through screening at us air this morning
as a personal item it's a little bit
bulky for purposes of getting on and off
the airplane but it replaces in fact the
yale university library copy which spent
two years in the mid-1970s residing on
top of a filing cabinet in my apartment
they actually in 1973 let me check out a
1679 book and take it home and renew it
indefinitely until I until I graduated I
had this put here by reason of helping
us think about quantity
because quantity is something that human
beings I find think about most
imperfectly indeed a Provost of a highly
selective institution has an experience
of this every time one of our loyal
alumni one of the loyal parents from our
community comes up to me and tells me
that they have a 17 year old child who
actually is extraordinarily bright and
would be just fine for Georgetown I am
obliged at that point to say thank you
very much you realize that we have
nineteen thousand applications for 1500
spaces up to which the parent will
always say yes I understand that but my
daughter is really bright the lack of
understanding which I try not to rub
their noses and at that point is that of
those nineteen thousand applications
there are on average 38,000 parents who
think that those children are in fact
really bright we need to use some other
selection mechanism other than taking
mom and dad's word for it in order to
decide which 1500 will wind up on the
campus and 1500 is in fact a small
percentage of 19,000 it's just plain
tough in fact the last numbers we saw
suggested of those 19,000 something like
2200 that is to say more than we have
seats for have graduated as first in
their class in high school that's how
smart really smart gets to be when
you've got those kind of numbers but ten
to one is a ratio that human beings
because we've got 10 fingers know
something about and in principle we can
do something with a ten to one ratio
when Maffei discovered the complexities
on the epistles by cassiodorus he knew
he was adding to the store of knowledge
so he was adding out of the sixteen
hundred or so columns in these two books
he was adding another hundred columns or
so appreciable not overwhelming but
weren't so dull it might be more
significant but nevertheless making a
real contribution to the store of what
we had from from the 6th century since
this time I would say the most important
thing that has happened is that one of
cassiodorus most important books was
given a really good addition in 1937
it's a book which excuse me cassiodorus
seems to put through several revisions
and
movements over time and so working the
manuscript tradition to figure out what
was the archaic form what was the first
round of Corrections what was the second
round of directions that's what people
like me do that's what people like me
enjoy reading about and so on that one
particular regard the addition of his
Institute's that we now use as far
better than what's in these books and
should not the one in these work should
not be consulted other works have been
edited they have been improved in a
variety of ways and they are now much
better than they were in the 19th
century but you would not go so far
wrong if you read from this collection
that's good news for a very important
reason which is to say that wherever you
are and whatever you are doing if you
are a member of the columbia university
community and you have a decent wireless
connection you can read these books
because about 15 years ago a commercial
publisher decided to produce the online
patra loggia latina database digitized
everything in these 225 volumes sold it
to libraries at a a substantial price
and Pat Renfro and I had a conversation
about it in those days when she was
buying them and I was not quite sure I
wanted to recommend that they be that
they be bought and irony of that which I
will mention only in passing is it means
that I now spend much more time in the
digital age paying attention to the 19th
century editions of cassiodorus than I
ever did before because these are with
me on the train with my wireless
broadband but the well printed not
digitally available bulky volumes of the
best editions those are back in my
office and my office at least is a place
where they don't leave me a whole lot of
time to play with such things so here's
the issue I want to frame and and
juxtapose in the world which mentally
most of us as scholars grew up we're
trained live and breathe this kind of
object and my face kind of discovery
constitutes normal scholarship in my
lifetime we've had two of those
discoveries in the works of Agustin for
example
25 letters were discovered in the 1970s
another 20 or so sermons were discovered
in the 1990s another half dozen sermons
were discovered a year or two ago and I
felt particularly proud because when
they asked me whether I would approve
the research project which involved
going around and cataloging those
manuscripts I recommended in favor of it
so I thought I had helped find those
sermons total quantity of enhancement of
agustn's works on that is by quantity
trivial although some of the letters are
indeed quite interesting and help fill
in the gaps for some stories we didn't
know before and we're glad we have what
i learned from paganism edublogs calm is
that those days are over for a reason
that I think sometimes escapes attention
and that is that whatever we do and
however faithfully we continue to carry
out the of amenia the ship yoma faii of
the discovery of manuscripts work that
we have practiced for hundreds of years
we are now doing so in an environment
that has changed dramatically we are
surrounded by quantities of information
beyond our imagining it's not a ten to
one ratio it's far larger than that and
whatever you imagine the ratio to be now
remember this it was 15 years ago this
month but Netscape Navigator was
released for the first time mosaic the
first graphical web browser was about a
year older than that I used to say in
the talks like this i gave 15 years ago
that netscape was the commercial product
with the most rapid market penetration
of any product in history within
literally weeks anyone who had mosaic
had converted to Netscape and copies
were morphing throughout the universe
this space in which we imagine ourselves
living and whose magnitude we cannot
begin to imagine is only 15 years old we
turned on the fire hose we turned on all
the fire hydrants 15 years ago that's
fine and 150 years from now please not
the length of time with those
manuscripts spent sitting on top of the
chapter library armoire in Verona just
how much will have come from the fire
hose by the
what will it mean in that world to have
imagined publishing so let me go back ah
sorry one more set of numbers that i
want to delink erro ver this will also
give you some quantity for where the
problem has gotten already Brian lavoie
arrived was Schoenfeld of Ithaca the the
melon spin-off organization did a study
now four years ago of the age of books
and research libraries I say this what's
in Butler it's these aren't butler
numbers these are oclc numbers based on
research libraries they went in and
looked at the total number records the
total number of holdings of books in
OCLC libraries and looked at them by
date and look at that only eighteen
percent of what you find in research
libraries is pre 1923 why do we care
because 1923 is the date before which
everything is presumptively out of
copyright and available in the public
domain after 1923 for complicated legal
reasons the public domain ishness of
things deteriorates rapidly Google's
working assumption is that if it's
published after 19 23 printed after 1923
they will treat it as in copyright
because they can't be absolutely sure
without some work but it's not and on
the other hand when they did this study
1977 to 2005 was responsible for over
four fifty percent of the materials my
own PhD is in 1975 that means that
already four years ago more than half of
what the modern American research
library holds had been published after I
got my doctoral dissertation if we have
continued at four more years producing
material and bringing in at the rate at
which we bring it in that fifty percent
number has probably migrated forward a
couple of more years we're probably up
to the early Reagan years by now in the
situation in the short term is not
getting any better that's already
immense quantity with which to have to
deal no surprise that one of the most
attention getting book titles of the
last year and a book that I am
recommending to everyone I now meet
because it was reviewed so on
comprehensive book is pure by ards how
to write about how to talk about books
you haven't read it was reviewed by and
large by people to took it serious
Lee and did not recognize the irony by
our theme is more the fact that we all
live in a space in which most of the
books that exist by a vast proportion
our books we haven't read and we do in
fact talk about them in one form or
another all the time it's a more subtle
and sophisticated book than that and I
strongly recommend it but it's a book
for our time in which the possibility of
mastering the literature on any subject
is if it was ever a truism has
disappeared from us once and for all so
I come back to my initial concerns with
learned societies and publication and
learned societies if this is what's
happened to the world already if this is
what the world is turning into and what
it will become what does it mean now to
publish so let me go through the obvious
it means to select identify bring
together revise and edit work of Merit
we know how to do that the editors of
the transaction to the American for the
logical association know how to do that
by and large we get a hundred or so
submissions a year we select from them
40 or so we work on them very hard we
copy edit them we make sure their
footnotes are all in good order we go
back and forth to the auditor to the
author and we produce something of
extraordinarily high quality all right
we know how to do that provide the work
a secure channel for distribution we
know and we don't know how to do that
printing binding and mailing whatever it
is the post office charges us we know
how to do that distributing
electronically we're pretty sure we know
how to do that the APA in fact backed
into electronic publication we suffer
from the embarrassment that we our
journal is in fact housed in JSTOR the
back issues of JSTOR and at the time
when the issues were first released in
JSTOR no officer or employee of the APA
could actually remember signing a
contract allowing them to do that we
later found out that we had but it just
kind of happened one day when we weren't
looking we publish now with the johns
hopkins university press and as you will
most of you into it that means that we
also distribute through project muse
that's where our current issues are ours
Oracle run is am j storm well we think
we're knowing how that we know how to do
that that is a secure channel for
distribution it probably doesn't read my
reach my colleague dr. Shaw in in food
on and it certainly doesn't reach a good
many of the people at my meeting in New
Delhi a couple of weeks ago abhiyan
places and people in the united states
that you would think it reaches i was
startled the other day that a colleague
at Arizona State University told me that
she does not have access to the
thesaurus lingua grike I the standard
collection of Greek texts of classical
Greek literature online ASU does not
have a classics department per se and
has never paid the small number of
hundreds of dollars of subscription for
what I take for granted as the resource
that of course every scholar has it has
access to she tells me that she still
writes to her colleague at Duke
University who runs the searches for her
and sends the results back when she
wants to wants to find things the
channel of distribution may be secure
but if it's not actually reaching even
that primary audience much less a new
and growing audience then the security
of that channel is one thing but one
more piece of work is that we must
ensure the preservation of the work for
as long as the author of the editor and
the readers think useful and I think it
is fair to say summarizing a great deal
of work by a great many hard-working
responsible serious authoritative people
that we ain't there yet there's a lot of
good work has been done there are
projects that know how to preserve
digital objects I will be the hundred
and fifty year perspective person right
now and say we won't know for another
hundred and thirty-five years whether we
have figured out how to keep this kind
of information available usable
accessible for that kind of period of
time that will depend a lot on
technology and it will depend even more
on human beings to care about this stuff
in order to make sure that particular
things of value remain considered to be
things of value as they go forward but
the last thing a publisher does and the
reason why they always tell you not to
publish your own novel yourself but to
get a real publisher is not any of those
first things but in need to make sure
that you can bring your work
to the attention of an audience and
Harper Collins is much better at
bringing work to the attention of an
audience than I personally am even if I
master the techniques of blog and
Twitter and viral marketing the
traditional publisher has known in
European European style industrialized
societies how to attract the attention
of an audience of how to provide
channels through which of the person who
would really use the information is able
to find that information and make some
use of it those days it seems to me are
really gone at this point when the
challenge for finding material in this
set of fire hoses the set of fire
hydrants producing information is
already considerable those of you who
teach will know the challenge of making
sure that your students come back with
information that is reliable the the
paganism blog that I showed you is an
extreme case I doubt that any of my
students will actually cut and paste
text from that page to put into a paper
for me I hope that if they do I will
detect it fairly readily I hope this
will happen across the country and
across the world but I cannot always be
certain that this will happen let me
give you an example of how that can be
challenging I started to tell a
different story about this this morning
about 35 years ago in those graduate
student days a colleague of mine and I
published a joke festschrift in honor of
one of our venerated teachers who is
leaving Yale University to teach at
Southern Methodist his name was Jeremy
Adams we called it the lemon Tatiana is
year Mei which is the name of the book
of the Bible of the lamentations of
Jeremiah we thought lamentations of
Jeremy sounded pretty good we all wrote
articles on that parodied the work we
were doing ourselves had done with
Jeremy my colleague Stuart Jenks now
professor of medieval history at the
University of erlangen-nuremberg was
working on the black death in 14th
century verts Berg he grew up in
Southern California and so his article
was on the black death in 14th century
Los Angeles as sort of as you 23 well I
was about to tell you about the evil
time ten years ago when there were
things like info seek around
pretending to bring together and
organize and manage the information of
the web in authoritative ways i was
going to fish out the screen grab that
stuart and i got when his article about
the black death and 14th century los
angeles got picked up by two different
sites like that so i came in here this
morning to look this up did the google
search and from ppl you GD you a page
about the black death look down at the
one that's a little bit purple black
death in the queue itas the testimony of
the anonymous los angeles's there it is
cuit asin austria domino ragini angle or
on the testimonials anonymous los
angeles that's the map which accompanied
it the collars silwa sunk die that's
Hollywood Hills this shouldn't fool
anybody but in fact it's now been
fooling people for about 15 years I used
to use this as an example of the poor
quality of material found on the web but
I think I've learned something different
as well it's not the poor quality of
material found on the web that's the
problem poor quality of material has
been with us for a long time Agustin
would have told me since the Garden of
Eden as a matter of fact a fair amount
of nonsense a fair amount of drivel has
been written and disseminated at all
ages of human history that's not the
problem the problem is the selection
mechanism how you go about finding in a
world of dispersed attention the
material of the highest possible quality
when that mechanism breaks down when
academics are telling you to read this
because they haven't had enough time to
read it they haven't had enough time to
look at it and it sounds good the title
has Latin in it after all sorry I'm
respecting your remember in a recent
sequel to inspector Morris on PBS in
which the man
so this is Oxford some everything here
means something in Latin lots of things
still mean something if you don't have
mechanisms for finding and filtering
your way through the vast quantity of
material that we have you will not find
authoritative information and it is not
entirely the fault of our students that
they with what skills we have provided
them do not always find the best article
the best journal in the best place what
I want to suggest for publishing and for
learning societies this is my point and
I open it as a question and a
possibility is to say that the
traditional mechanisms that I spoke of a
few minutes ago for identifying what
constitutes publication those first
three channels are the ones where we
have concentrated our effort or time at
the moment I would say the American fill
illogical Association has out sourced
item number four to the johns hopkins
university press and JSTOR and we trust
them to go out and find an audience for
us our other audiences members of our
association there are hey three thousand
of those they know all about the journal
we don't need to market it to them what
I am struck by as we look forward and
think about how journals serious
publications scholarly publication can
and will survive is that in a world in
which there is a very very large
quantity of poor quality material
there's also going to be a very very
large quantity of you know pretty good
material and a very very large quantity
of really quite good almost good enough
material you can decide for yourselves
which of those categories you want to
put Wikipedia in based on the last
Wikipedia article you read
differentiating and achieving mindshare
again from a worldwide audience
including people who don't have the
advantages of moving to and fro and
butler library when there isn't just the
first rate quality information but
there's also the really quite good
quality information and they're really
almost good enough quality information
and they are all at pains to masquerade
for another does it seems to me impose a
new obligation on those who care about
the highest quality information
not simply to distribute it with the
appropriate brand and trust the world to
come and find it but to think instead
about what it is we have to do in order
to bring that to the attention of a
wider world and that seems to me to be
potentially destabilizing in an
interesting and possibly productive way
for learnin societies to think of
ourselves as having to market our
discipline as much as to represent and
guide and protect it is unfamiliar for
most of it the APA has another
publication that I am not responsible
for it's called M forum it is our
outreach divisions newsletter it's
really quite engaging it has
illustrations it has stories about
recent discoveries of archaeology it has
entertaining stories about the classics
in modern film and at the same time it
reaches its audience with some
difficulty the one audience we know our
outreach newsletter always reaches is
members of the association who get a
free copy mailed to them all the time
that doesn't quite qualify as outreach
yet but we know we have not yet found a
way in which to in which to distribute
our information through that channel
that really reaches a wider audience are
we good at marketing can we do marketing
I think at the end of a talk I gave some
years ago to something called the
Society for college and university
planners a crowded auditorium in in
Vancouver in the days when I guess I
counted as a neat internet evangelist at
the end of the talk somebody back in row
23 stood up and said I was struck that
you were using the word marketing not so
much you're a classics professor what do
you know about that kind of subject I
had an answer for him it was my answer
then it's my answer now and it's a
hopeful answer and that is but marketing
after all was invented for us by the
Greeks they just called it rhetoric
seems to me that we have some hope if we
can imagine understand our cultural
history to think about ways to learn
again from the Greeks and to learn again
from ourselves something of the answers
to the kind of problems that we posed
for ourselves thank you
occasionally people write books but not
to present new material both scientists
probably have never written a book and
society the connection between the
journals and society is somewhat
different mean so for example the
american physical society publishes
journals important journals not so much
for the members twenty-seven percent of
what we publish is comes from the US and
even if a high fraction of those authors
are aps members certainly most of the
seventy-three percent from elsewhere or
not and the scale of things is somewhat
different I mean Jim was talking about
the fire hose coming from Boggs have no
like the APS gets a new paper submitted
every 15 minutes 24 7 ok and publishers
about half of them that's about 19,000
papers a year and there are a few other
good journals around too so just keeping
track of that is keeping track is a real
task actually we have gotten into
marketing the APS now has a thing called
physics an email they send once a week
if you sign up for it to scientists
which tells you four or five important
papers of that week and of course if you
have time you might be able to read the
email let alone yeah ok I know and then
it gives you blurbs about the articles
you know actually to read the article
yeah now there's also all sorts of
things like the paganism org there are
blogs out there that will tell you that
Einstein was wrong and so those I don't
think or a problem um people can filter
that out
the journals are due serve so far really
as a indication of what is considered
valid of course neater which journal to
trust and which not on but i think the
non journal literature is not so much a
problem for us now what is a problem
what's certainly an issue that
librarians with budgets will have to
worry about as time goes on is what the
internet is done is let not just
amateurs put things online but let
serious authors put everything online
when i write a paper i post it online
and then maybe a week later i send it
through a turtle okay um the mechanism
in my field the mechanism for this has
been the e-print archive which started
at Los Alamos and is now Cornell you can
post a paper there there is a minimal
filtering so an obvious crackpot paper
doesn't doesn't get posted but almost
anything else will get post it ah you
can put it in a perfectly fine format I
can using latex format something as well
as an eternal can um if you're not an
English speaker it may not be in very
good English but that could be done ah
so it's up there it's freely accessible
okay so we might ask why do we need
journals why do people want journals
well traditionally the journal did
several things it did peer review which
certifies the validity both to other
scientists in the field who may not feel
they can't charge it for themselves
but also to deans and Provost's and
department chairs and like who might be
making decisions about hiring promotions
and so on ok that the archive can't do
then the journals did formatting copy
editing essays I say I said that you can
do for yourself now the journals do
translating taking quasi English into
English and that certainly is a value of
it and then they distributed an archive
it that really can be done by the
archive down you know in fact people
more certainly Michael that high energy
physics commonly if you know a paper has
been published in a journal you respect
you will then go to the archive to get a
copy to read because you can access the
archived anywhere you happen to be where
is to access the journal you either have
to be at your institution or if your
institution allows you to log in
remotely you can go in through a few
steps that get it there but the archive
is absolutely free okay so what's how do
people feel about this well certainly
when the archive first appeared there
was some speculation that people would
stop submitting to journals that hasn't
happened in my field i would say
essentially a hundred percent certainly
I would say a hundred at least 99 f %
probably truly a hundred percent of the
papers that physical review d publishers
that's four thousand papers are on the
archive usually before the journal
accepts it in some cases they're posted
after okay but if you go the other way
if you ask if you go to the archive now
the archive post you can post things
like conference proceedings and so on
which wouldn't be a pro
read for a journal but if you look at
the article type things posted on the
archive essentially a hundred percent of
them are submitted to journals the
authors do want the peer review they
want the stamp of validity that a
journal will give now you could be
cynical and say that's because they care
about the deans provost chairs and so on
that want to get promoted and so on but
as you know in excremental high-energy
physics there are some fairly large
collaborations you know we get papers
with 600 700 authors soon it will be
2,000 once the new accelerator and
Geneva starts working okay so if you're
one of 700 people listed alphabetically
so if you're mr. aaltonen or our bay or
so on then you'll become very well known
but otherwise you're lost in the middle
there is no indication of who did the
primary work on that particular paper
it's absolutely useless in terms of
judging individuals exciting on
promotions and hiring in addition these
collaborations have a lot of internal
review before they submit a paper
nevertheless they submit all of their
papers to journals when I look at the
referee reports generally these are
refereed more carefully than theoretical
papers with only a few authors and there
will be lots of arguing if say the
referee says this isn't good enough for
the letters journal it should go into
the regular Journal they'll be lots of
Arkham back and forth so people care
about the publishing even when it's not
a question of individual promotions
and like but there's a worry okay uh
right now you could say if I were a
librarian I might say well if all of the
material is on freely available at the
archives and you can know it's public
information when a paper has been
accepted by a journal why don't you just
wait to see if it's been accepted by a
journal you respect then go read it on
the archive and then we won't have to
pay for a subscription okay uh well
right now that's not an issue because
it's only i would say high energy
physics is the only field where it's
really a hundred percent coverage other
fields it's part which is spotty in both
math and physics the coverage is partial
or not affect you certainly do really
need to have the journal to be able to
read all the literature that you want to
read but that could change you know
suppose that the archive percentage goes
up in other fields okay then Joran van
libraries might be tempted to cancel
subscriptions but this is something you
peer review is something that the
community wants i think is very
important for scholarly public
publication but the real costs okay if I
looked up the APS data which is online
the cost per paper not not the charged a
lot to library the actual cost of it
cost to the APS of producing a paper
it's about eight hundred fifty dollars
per submitted paper which comes to about
1600 / published paper and a little bit
of that is from
physical production of a journal for the
places that still actually receive
hardcopy journals but most of that is
for things editorial work if you have
35,000 papers coming in to be sent out
to referees and referee reports to be
analyzed and may be sent to another
referee that's a lot of professional
staff that you need to do that you need
also lots of IT backup because all of
this is done electronically now you do
need even online things to have to be
typeset maybe isn't the right word would
have to be put into a proper format and
the servers have to be maintained and so
on so that's will cost now most
scientific societies there's a little
bit actually charge libraries a little
bit more and goes to other activities of
the society education Public Affairs
forget that suppose you just wrote that
offset the society can matter to somehow
it to get the money otherwise this
little question of how do you pay for
the editorial process you know 48 for
physics for APS that's 30 million
dollars they're talking about where is
it going to come from well seems to me
the possibilities are the readers which
effectively the ones paying now except
libraries pay for us okay ah the authors
which i'll come back to or third parties
maybe you need to say maybe the
government will do that maybe we can get
the NSF to pay for scientific journals
well not sure you could particularly if
they say seventy-three percent of them
those authors are foreigners living
elsewhere and that's a so many people
say I have the author's pay
they're there can be unexpected
consequences the model and physics used
to be that they were page charges so
when I was much younger he paid fifty
dollars a page maybe for every article
that was published and that's one fifty
dollars was fifty dollars was real money
you know I could even buy lunch for that
well at some point around 1979 Physical
Review raised its Chargers from
something like seventy dollars a page to
eighty dollars a page not a big
difference but what happened some
research groups decided they couldn't
pay that increase so they started
subscribing they started submitting to a
journal published by a commercial
publisher whom I won't name then others
started doing that and very quickly most
of the best work was being submitted to
this commercial journal saving the
research groups lots of money in page
charges ah but unbeknownst to them
increasing tremendously the cost to the
libraries and this could happen now your
will people talk about open access well
open access means the readers don't that
it doesn't mean somebody has to pay for
the cost and it's a problem whose
solution i don't know and i will leave
it for the
for the moment it's not it for the
moment it's not there because the
archive hasn't penetrated enough but the
time will come and I think it's going to
be problems which I do not yet know the
answer okay maybe I should stop now now
I think you have questions for both of
us let me maybe put a footnote on that
last comment I think you've highlighted
that the production and distribution of
academic widgets differs from the
production distribution of most other
widgets the only reason you would pay
page charges to have your article
published is if there's real benefit to
you of a non-monetary variety or not
directly safe variety from doing this
and there are too many stakeholders in
this who have who have different kinds
of financial interests the librarian has
a particular financial interest of
wanting to get all possible information
for users without direct reference to
whether it ever actually gets used or
not and that it's also an unusual kind
of transaction I think I buy books that
way but I don't know many other people
buy any object in the I'll buy all of it
there is in case I ever need to use some
of it but we recognize that is perfectly
rational libraries but it creates
difficult for the economist to analyze
incentives in the system or they will
buy a journal not knowing what
percentage they might want exactly yeah
sure okay yes hello sir my name is Lisa
Winokur i'm liu student from palmera
library science I have more of a
question it's more of a comment you said
with open access someone has to pay
whoever advertising like on this site
itself possible
or whether it has the New York Times
about it though they're having problems
getting of money advertising online no I
that's a potentially viable that's it
that's a potentially valuable thing I
don't know that say you'd get enough
people interested in advertising and
physical review to make enough money how
much I'm talking more the online
databases the kermes are suggesting that
trend to make them to lower down the
cost these are people who have related
products and get their their product
line known to the consumer in principle
I I don't see any objection whether I
would be surprised if you could make
enough money that way thank you sir let
me let me put in that an analogy for
this of an example of open access that
is failing before our eyes and failing
astonishingly television once upon a
time advertising paid for television and
all the television content was free now
you pay for the television content it's
not the pay-tv of 40 or 50 years ago pay
per view I don't know what the numbers
are on that but the fundamental model
according to which essentially all of us
have been suckered into paying for TV
and getting the ads is not paying for
program it's not even paying per channel
I wish you could pay for channel I wish
I could select three channels what I
want and see those channels please
instead of having to upgrade twenty nine
dollars a month in order to get the one
channel but we've been moved toward a
subscription model toward an information
service which gives us in the full form
TV and movies and music I know somebody
who's got a hundred and forty seven
channels of music that comes with their
package their premium package and so
forth and that has gotten people to
cough up the money in order to to get
the product even while the advertising
still stays there I guess the lesson I
would draw from that
is that over time these relationships
are in fact market relationships and
when people think the advertising really
works they'll pay for advertising I
think it doesn't they won't at the
moment the last 10 years google has done
quite well on the idea that people are
willing to pay extraordinary amounts in
in some totals little bits at a time for
google kind of advertising I am very
proud of the fact that I never noticed
any advertising on Google and I never
respond to any of it i'm sure i don't
okay but subliminally the like the
likelihood except i like in my gmail i
like the funny ones that show up where
has picked up some word in my mail and
given me the improbable answer but I
would only say there's probably some
future moment at which there's an
article in the online Wall Street
Journal that google ad revenues are
plummeting because and I don't know
enough to know what the because is there
when that would happen but it isn't
guaranteed that Google will be able to
be Google based on ad revenues forever
for whole variety of reasons Am I I
found your plea for scholarly societies
to get the high quality information out
worldwide to be really appealing and you
didn't intone by that talk about open
access directly remember and I'm just
interested in your thoughts on open
access is the solution to that I mean
clearly marketing on the part of the APS
doesn't help much it's a scholar in
China can't afford for his institution
to purchase this material and we've
recently seen this announcement from
five institutions for this compact on
open access publishing which is a an
effort to change this model and to say
let's have institutional funds that
would back up non grant funded
publication charges I'm just curious how
you would look at that is that a
possible solution to this well I like
free
I like things that are free i like to
get them for nothing and i recognize it
for variety of reasons i don't always
succeed in in doing so i guess i would
say that i think that this little war
that librarians and academics are on the
edge of about open access is in the
medium to long term a distraction from
the larger question of how we're going
to produce develop sustain distribute
high quality information for a wide
audience I'm perfectly prepared to
believe that you can make information
available free if somebody else pays for
it I'm perfectly prepared to believe it
you can even drive the price down I mean
look apple with itunes has proven that
you can sell songs for 99 cents which
you didn't use to get to do i think
forty-fives back when I was young
probably cost 99 cents inflation is
kicked in but they've discovered that if
you break it down into the granular
product sell it for a low enough price
you can sell a whole lot of things and
maybe that model works I will instance
and if any of you know my habits and
giving talks its not surprised that I do
so the case of Beanie Babies beanie
babies are the small plush toys that
were introduced about 15 years ago by a
guy who used to sell stuffed animals for
a big company and thought he saw an
opportunity and he created a craze that
lasted for about five years on the
discovery that 595 was a price point at
which the American kid could buy a whole
lot of individual stuff toys Cabbage
Patch dolls had been the craze of a
decade before but by the time you had
two or three $39 Cabbage Patch dolls you
had about as many Cabbage Patch dolls as
you and the whole neighborhood needed to
see for one whole lifetime but you make
them six inches tall and you make them
cute and you continue to diversify them
and the average American kid could buy
200 of those and always be ready to buy
be ready to buy one more so maybe we can
drive the price down to where it is low
enough to be negligible and I would say
a revenue stream that didn't come from
India and China and was in
the pennies per might actually turn out
to be in fact of India and China become
big customers pennies per from India and
China could probably float a fair number
of editors and publishers we don't know
I'm empirical about that I'm struck as
I'm in the middle of these arguments in
a variety of ways that when I pull back
and try to take a longer perspective on
these things up to me the problem isn't
in the end that we can do something that
we can afford to pay for doing it it's
that when you produce I'll make it to
the principle of supply and demand when
you produce an infinite quantity of
supply the value of the individual
artifact begins to approach zero you may
not read every article in your field
these days it's just possible and that's
a way of saying not every article in
your field is as exciting and important
to you as others you're making a choice
and if there are a thousand articles a
year coming out that I must read of
those articles as individual items
whatever I may think about them
notionally are going to be of lower
value I'll do one number that I was
looking at the other day there's a
standard bibliography of classical
scholarship colony philology and
published in Paris since 1920 it seeks
to index everything published in a given
academic year in the fields of Greek and
Latin when I graduated from college it
was doing eight thousand items a year in
the last published volume which is five
years ago because it takes a while to do
all of this they were up to seventeen
thousand items doesn't feel to me as
though the discipline of classics is
twice as large as it was when I was
young but I do know that I I'm having
trouble keeping up with the stuff
because they're really genuinely is
twice as twice as much of it managing
that kind of quantity imagining that
kind of quality forward seems to me to
be the real problem that will control
what we can do and pricing by comparison
to that to me is it's a small issue it's
one that can be worked out empirically
and yeah I'm all in favor of free but
I'm also all in favor of the people who
do this not going broke because when
they go broke
don't get the information either
dr. O'Donnell you said something about
we having practiced scholarship a
certain way for hundreds of years and
how that model is changing but it occurs
to me that it's not only the model
that's changed but also the way that
that then and compasses that we add a
number among the wii that's been
practicing scholarship you're away for
hands of years as manuscripts are being
made available online they're being sort
of democratized and the wii has expanded
to include people like your friend from
china and me a mother of true with three
jobs who can do her PhD because her
research is sitting on her lap right now
and this clogs the job pool I understand
but then perhaps on the infinite quality
of supply the infinite quantity I mean
to say not quality of supply that might
just drive us to aspire to more you know
it drives us to aspire higher to almost
impossible scholarly feats you know
because of the competition I wondered
about what you thought about the
positive side perhaps of all of this
digital possible oh I think I think oh
there during men's positive side i
recognized dinosaurus characteristics in
myself I found the one volume Oxford
standard authors Boswell's life of
Johnson for ten bucks in a bookstore
yesterday and I couldn't control myself
I read it twice before I may never read
it again but I have it there was no
choice it had to follow me home no
matter what that's a curious curious
practice in its own right yes I what we
have trained traditionally we human isms
particularly if trained traditionally
our students and ourselves to think that
information is limited in quantity and
that success means developing the
hunter-gatherer skills to go out and
find every single piece of information
and then put it together in an
absolutely convincing pattern okay
multiply the quantity of information by
two orders of magnitude and you can't do
that anymore we don't yet as historians
as researchers are the kind of things
work on have a theory that we can live
with of how you would do sampling and
surveying and averaging on your evidence
because we are so caught in this model
of ourselves as one hunter-gatherers who
go find that one more article that's
going to solve this problem for us
growing up in and imagining yourself
living in a space that is too large for
you to control that way you will develop
other techniques of control that will be
functionally equivalent but possible for
an actual human being to manage at this
point to say to a young person getting
out of college you wish to work on the
writings of st. Agustin okay there's
five million words in Latin available
and the bibliography has been growing
alarmingly for the last few generations
go away and read it all and come back
when you're serious it's not going to
happen but there is work that can and
should be done there are questions that
need asking questions we can't answer
and techniques that will evolve to to
answer them and I happily recognize that
it will be the innovators of each next
generation that will find the ways to do
this in a persuasive fashion I'd say
certainly the web and moving to
electronic publishing has democratized
things I mean certainly are 15 years ago
before most scientific journals were
online the University of Delhi could get
copies of those journals and probably to
save costs they would be shipped by sea
and arrive several months later feels
where several months makes a big
difference now they can be read well
they're certainly from the journal as
soon as the journal publishes them if
they have a subscription they can get it
if it's on the archive they can get that
several months earlier reports for
published by the terminal and certainly
I think until in terms of trying to
understand how but what the new
financial model is going to be
we need to recognize that there are
parts of the world where people can't
pay the same amount of money that can be
paid here I imagine the University of
Delhi library budget is a little bit
smaller than Columbia's you know you
mentioned the twenty-seven percent of
authors who are united states I think
I've seen from the physics publishers
the charts showing how that has changed
in fact that's a measure of the
democratization that more and more
articles well from more and more
countries well it's a very interesting
chart the physical review has they plot
online you know the number of
submissions and if you look us
submissions have been absolutely flat
for about 20 years as has us support for
government support for physics adjusted
for inflation but you see Europe going
up a bit and Asia just rising I'm Ron
musto and one of the co-directors of the
ACLS humanities ebook initiative will be
reporting to gym tomorrow as a member of
our board I want to make two points that
never and also a publisher refine books
to of a more traditional variety apart
yes softcover paper books which still
sell very well thanks I want to
reiterate two points that primarily Jim
made one is a non ideological approach
to open access that we do live in a
mixed economy and a mixed approach is
probably the best that we should take
for example even on our own site we have
open access tiles and titles that we put
behind a subscription wall and I do
believe it is a distraction right now
the discussion things will evolve in
which the notion of sustainability is
put in its proper perspective and and
the proper agents of that sustainability
will be brought forward and the second
is Jim's point that we bring down the
unit cost of these things so that
they're practically open access in fact
we're working right now on negotiations
with both chinese consortium and in
in consortium that if they're successful
the unit price of a monograph per year
will be someplace between eight and
twelve cents a year from one of our
monographs and if you divide that over
the actual retail price of a monograph
that's about 400 years worth of
monograph per title so that these things
are in the works and they are within the
realm of possibility of practical
possibility yeah let me just say in
terms of pricing I mean Philly the more
you distribute the lower the unit cost
but for example for journal articles one
irreducible thing you want is that the
paper be refereed and you need full-time
paid people managing that process
sending things out two referees
evaluating the reports and so on and
just that part of the process is going
to cost several hundred dollars per
paper I would emphasize in connection
with that that the non dollar part of
that in many disciplines and parts of
disciplines is not insignificant when I
think of the issues in our learning
society one that affects me is the
availability of volunteer talent of very
high quality and its willingness to
spend time on peer reviewing and
editorial functions there's only so much
of that talent that you I think you're
ever going to get out of American
classics professors and no matter what
we want to think about how we could
organize material better we could in
principle do something if you don't get
more people like me than there are
people like me who are willing to do
some of that stuff to do it it just
won't get done at a good quality and
that's the problem with the Black Death
article it's not that anybody wanted to
put crap on their website it's that they
didn't have enough time and talent and
enough patience to go through and
differentiate a joke from
from something serious
you